so thanks for joining us for Veronica's
Q&A we had her keynote last night to
talk a little bit about cybersecurity
risks and also maybe I felt like it was
slightly a call to action a little bit
for us as data folks machine learning
folks to maybe start to apply our skills
into problem-solving in this space so we
want to continue that conversation today
I don't know if you have any opening
comments or anything from the
conversations that you've had in the
past day or so here yeah so I would be
great to know a bit of your background
but we are so few and so if you and for
example what what is your interest in
India cybersecurity and machine learning
based on the talk yesterday and if you
think there is any let's say struggle or
how do you get started or or how is how
is the what do you think you need to
help for example so we can have a
conversation around that my my
background is is more like a threat
research apply to to work with much
learning people so so that is something
that we I think we can discuss all that
so cool and we'll use mics use mic so
that the recording gets of the
conversation if that's fine so I'll just
share with you and pass them if you want
to give us the right direction I don't
know if you want to go to Sebastian yes
so thank very much I'm Sebastian I'm
researching in machine learning and
security in the Czech Technical
University in Prague and we are building
a set of tools and methods to help
society by using machine learning in
security space as we can so yeah
close topic let's say to this thank you
hi first of all I have to say I wasn't
able to attend the keynote yesterday
which is why I'm here to try and like
catch a and discuss some of these issues
I'm a data scientist freelancer
currently working with a company that
works with Wi-Fi network management
though I work with logs data to do with
signals and yeah some overlap although
their main focus is not intruding
intrusion detection but yeah I'm
interested ok cool cool thank you hi I'm
um I'm a security specialist okay and
I'm here to learn something about
machine learning and data science at all
because I think it's a huge area where
we have a lot of missing knowledge in
the community thank you we are yes ok so
just doing a small recap of yesterday
keynote was the point that I wanted to
convey yesterday was that we well we
need to think about cyber security
because is it affecting a real life like
physical life in ways that we never
expected before right the ability right
now from Alwar taking out of or
electricity I'm going from software
through the real life is it was not seen
20 years ago so this is one of the
things where we should get better at
detecting like malware cyber threats and
cyber attacks right and the thing is
that we from how I see it right now
we're we got really good at creating
storage capabilities we know that for
example us have like huge data storage
facilities
we at Cisco have like in our group we
have 1 million users and the thing is
how do you detect things that are going
on in such huge amount of data right
it's not feasible for any human analyst
even if for example I would want to to
sift through the data and try to find
something because it's impossible right
some in a small company you have input
data from the web traffic of your users
you have if you have agents on the
endpoints you can gather data from there
you have the Wi-Fi you have logs all
type of logs and then you collect them
and the thing is that you have terabytes
of information sitting there so what do
you do right so that's why I believe
that there is no there's no way on not
using machine learning and there is a
huge thanks to marketing they trade you
the buzz words of machine learning
everyone is in machine learning people
start to say machine learning doesn't
work and it's not it's like saying I the
chair doesn't work well the person who
you use a chair it may work or not or
depending for what right and in there is
really it gets really interesting
because iPhone of mine from my point of
view that I my job is analyzing network
traffic I cannot do it without the tools
and machine learning you see at another
tool that let us reduce the amount of
data like instead of having to look at
one terabyte of data can we look at our
tank max which is something that
actually you can do right so how do we
use these tools in order to achieve that
and I think yesterday they were like I
think two big challenges that I
presented that the first one was how to
get better at detecting things in real
time to to be able to respond when the
attacks are happening right now and the
other challenge was like imagine that
you are already compromised how how can
we detect things that escaped or curing
the
actions as fast as we can so we can
reduce the damage right if someone gets
through our Wi-Fi can we detect it
within a with a within a week or the
guy's going to leave there in the guest
network forever and this is the Tumen
area that I think that we are lacking
right now and not in like in general
right as Arthur's security industry and
I think that for data scientists is is a
it's a very nice field to be able to
work with and forth we but the problem
that we are facing right now is that
cybersecurity people is looking into a
problem and now we are like ostracized
right it's like we tried to solve things
the same way we we try to solve twenty
years ago
and and we are making progress but it's
not that much and I think that the way
to crack this out is is through
diversity in a field like bringing
people from other backgrounds we
bringing people from physics bringing
people from from art design right to
that give us the way to look at things
differently that's why I was talking
here and I was really excited because
like where is a bit intimidating there
is a lot of a roomful of data scientists
and but at the same time is like I would
love to see more people tackling
cybersecurity like this because we need
that right and not because we
cybersecurity we cannot do it we will do
it maybe in 50 years but we cannot
afford to take that long that's that's
kind of the main discussion some I'm
open to any questions or things that you
want to discuss so I don't talk for half
an hour doesn't even have any questions
right now
now here is how to do it yes yeah so
those so it is a very broad question but
say we that the first thing that we are
trying to tackle is we we want to still
be able to respond where we are tackling
in our group at least I can talk by my
my my experience we are trying to tackle
the second problem which is the after
phase like how we find stuff in a
network data day after week that happens
so how we respond to that for that we
consume a lot of network traffic we
focus on web proxy logs or net flows and
the problem the first problem we have is
that we have a lot of data a lot of they
done we in that initial phase when we
get all this input data we are we can
every algorithm it will take always too
long so what we did is to create a
series of layers combining different
machine learning techniques and one
piece of machine learning process the
data and it passes to another one and I
think that that that is one way to do it
that I think for my experience that I
evaluate the result it works pretty well
and in the first in the first layer we
have the anomaly detection which is it
is really simple it is very simple and
it's not very very good anomaly
detection has a lot of limitations and
it will give you a lot of false
positives but if you consider that after
anomaly detection there will be
something else
cleaning up it can work so what we do is
having small little anomaly detectors
and when I'm looking at data as a human
analyst I'm looking at for example an
URL and I'm saying like okay
my seems fishy because the name is I
don't know my war domain that comes
right well why why they usually taxes in
a domain like this okay but there's one
just one thing that I'm looking right
then I'm looking this is a personal
information being exfiltrated on the URL
is them is their people downloading
stuff is so you combine this you as a
human and Alice you are looking at all
these different things and then combine
them together so what we try to do is to
do exactly the same every animal
effector is really small and simple and
it and therefore it can be really fast
and each of those are looking at very
specific things like okay you look at
the length of the URL you look at there
are on the flights down and you look at
the profile of the user and so on and
each of them are looking at something
and giving any score like zero six zero
seven zero and things like that and then
there is one module after that that is
combining the verdicts and now you feel
safe that I think is it's really easy to
get started into the field it's like can
we do something really simple that
please find normal and finds militias
and from there you you can move on right
you can say like why this is not enough
how can I combine this with something
else but the amount of data you will
have there is already something that you
can work with it's like really small and
yesterday I was pointing out to a data
set that is called CPU 13 which was
created by Sebastian group in the Czech
Technical University and actually the is
the first that the most people in
machine learning and security they are
using the DARPA out of it which is from
1998 surveillance it's like they have
like quad scanning yeah we got really
good detecting bots kind it's like
really nicely right but we right now we
we try to affect things like I'm
uploading
company documents to Dropbox
right we want to take that or we want to
attack malware that will wait until you
open your bank account to actually
communicate with the command control
service so how do we do that and each
other has a combination of normal
traffic malicious traffic and background
traffic that you don't know what it is
and I was I was highlighting it
yesterday because his thumb yes is the
data from 2011 but still is not 1998
right and is the best data that I know
to get started which that says like okay
the first challenge should be can I take
this outta set and can I split on the
text with whatever I go I play with
malicious of normal and maybe detect
something on the background traffic that
it was not labeled before and once
yes excel and succeed on that okay
can I move to faster algorithms the it
depends on the challenges that we are
trying to attempt but yesterday I was um
I was going I presented it to challenges
and I presented three areas on how to
work with and the first one was you can
all you can work only on making
algorithm faster right because that is
just by itself an area that we need to
work with and then there are other two
areas is like you don't need to be an
expert trying to find new things you can
focus on trying to find known things
better and I think that that does it is
it's very good for getting started and I
guess small questions and about stated
so labels are they from that CTU dataset
or do you like how do you know something
is malicious in the first place yeah so
they see do 13 was created for research
purposes some they they took a normal
traffic from the university and of
course use anonymize and and then they
infected machines with specific Manoir
and and they captured the traffic on the
network so they they know with maladies
and
you know if you search you can know okay
this is a banker this is a stealer and
sintered at so it's it was carefully
created and that is also very rare and
common labels in orefield are an
existence that's yes thank you that now
you're doing a shift to like the flow
data I'm very curious about that because
yeah I don't know that much about
networking but I know that floaty that
has a lot of different information
versus use like trying to parse headers
or figure something out
I'm curious about kind of how that works
with the system that you currently have
or if you're having to change a lot of
them because maybe flow data is more
complex I don't know if this is true
well so far we are working with proxy
locks which I show some examples
yesterday basically whatever you do to
the web and compared to what net flows
information you have in net flows
proxy logs are amazing in net flow what
you see like in the basic net flow
format is really really simple like you
have a timestamp you have a source IP
just in a destination IP source port and
destination port and you have bytes but
it's like an aggregation of all the
connections so you don't know how much
wise wearing one request you know like
the aggregate aggregation so you have
some other statistics like packets a
duration of the flow and DDP flags and
in the the normal versions of simplest
version was net flow you only have that
that's it right some for as it was being
really challenging because in the case
for example I was telling yesterday that
you have
of servers where they have malicious and
normal behavior at the same time how do
you do that how do i model that right
expectation for example is like
aggressive exfiltration that you have
one user that is living tomorrow and
it's uploading all the documents it's
kind of easy because you will see that
the huge amount of data being
transferred out but if you have
something more cells like 10 Meg's they
still mix in a 9/10 mix tomorrow morning
it's normal right so that type of music
gets really difficult and most mostly
I'm much more win it flow and the good
thing about net flow is that we have
visibility in other protocols which is
really interesting because most of
course companies have the internal
application in with some reports but I
usually draw that stuff is internal so
it doesn't go through internet and
malware usually tends to in some cases
use where things and that if it gets
really interesting because we before we
had only web traffic and now we have FTP
we have DNS is aggregated we don't see
the requests but at least it's something
that we can we can have like okay can we
can we identify a behavior like a lot of
DNS requests without a following HTTP
requests or another connection to a
protocol that because you do DNS
requests to connect through to the web
for example so why I'm seeing like a lot
of flows going to DNS if and I'm not
seeing some follow up so then the tie
the rules that you need to start
creating are more like complex combining
different behaviors together and for
example one of the most interesting
cases we work with it was would they
want to cry ransom or which it was
interesting because we we just started
to winded flow data and we
we were able to see connections to
different parts and we start seeing
these two scanning two board four four
five which is a some misspelling and it
was so interesting and select but we
cannot know if it's one a cry or not
right we it might be some people just
scanning and then we say well but all
the holes are in in German why would a
system be scanning the internet for this
part and actually we conducted the
customers and we say we think that is
weird and they say well actually sir
it's not this latest read is a thread
that we know for the last 15 years it's
really held malware and it was like okay
okay it doesn't matter because for us is
like we saw this behavior and we could
detect that it was malicious for us it
was something positive but with other
port scanning it gets trickier because
for example like I don't know scanning
on internal networks there are companies
that still allow that and you can have
like hundreds of false positives so then
you have to think what what if I combine
a port scanning with connections to
specific host oh okay then you have a
pattern of behavior and that days I
think it gets really exciting because
for an analyst you have to start
thinking like the attacker
what could the attacker do what what is
next and that for us is really exciting
like okay you need to actually keep
learning because you know you are
getting outdated and they are moving
forward and you don't and then you stop
detecting things right some is some is I
think if we have less data but there are
other challenges that are very nice yeah
okay okay okay um so I know that we both
know Marian and she is a big skeptic
about using machine learning for static
malware analysis have you done any
static malware analysis like I know that
your background is varied so I don't
know if you've always worked with
Network data or if you've also done
studying of malware a code yeah so yeah
I mean Doug Irwin my but I haven't seen
yet really successful machine learning
use of static analysis but I believe
that it's not about the machine learning
itself is how you use it right so I
think we still didn't crack this up and
our main input of data right now is
network so we are very limited but I
have a colleague that is working on that
so far she's getting really exciting
results but it's like home again if that
works we the amount of data she will
need to process is huge and when you
when your work and that is there's
another reason why I was mentioning the
data set yesterday because many people
try the algorithms in really small that
data like are really really small and
really carefully prepared and they bake
you ate too much the data they work with
and when you plug algorithms like that
in real life they don't work right it's
like it happened to us it's been 10
years we are doing this right and when
we start getting more more data it's
like okay I stopped working why what did
we did wrong well is not prepared when
you have like companies or customers in
all part of the world what is normal
here is creating false positives else oh
who do you work with that right son I
think that in static analysis where we
are we are not there yet I
I want to believe you that is possible I
think that would be tremendously
important to to have something like that
but maybe for the next icon I can send
my colleague very perfect yeah yes now -
oh yeah well so you have malware usually
so for this code right and you have like
maybe two main ways to analyze that one
is executing the the program and
analyzing what it what it does
dynamically if the malware communicates
outside it will generate network traffic
so it goes to network traffic and you
study that and static analysis is more
analyzing the instructions in the code
and how does suffer it was actually
build and made instructions it's called
and things like that to try to without
executing trying to understand if it's
malicious or or not and part of just to
give the brief into the HSA of how I was
able to meet an amazing person like
Veronica is through this black hoodie
group that does a women's hacker camp
every year to do to learn static malware
analysis here in Germany so I can also
happily share the information with you
yeah it's kind of cool because I know
that there's some insecurity culture
similar to the data science culture
sometimes there's a difficulty in
creating diversity and that's fun to
have you know these programs to get more
diverse folks into security and hacking
and malware analysis as well as you know
then also talk about these data science
things you had other questions so do you
have any
okay I guess talking about all these
threats I'm just wondering what the
temperature of your office is like is it
always an emergency because you probably
have a better idea of everything that's
going on everywhere it like it can you
sleep well I can I sleep well good
question
yeah but the question is can you sleep
yeah well we we have we have there the
main processing of data is on my machine
learning so the machine learning is the
one that detects the stuff on the
network and most of the time when I work
is taking the output of the machine
learning and analyze it and putting the
analyst feedback on top of that and
telling the customer okay the machine
learning engines as it is malicious
it's probably are no high risk and what
I say is like yes this is malicious but
it belongs to this bonnet the bonnet or
the malware does these and this is how
you remedied so we put these extra
little thing there and so then once we
another even magic of the automation
right because one once I say something
is malicious I don't need to keep
tracking tracking it all the time I can
tell their researchers I already know
what it is and they will manage to let's
say automatically detect that and so the
next time the customer will see oh this
is a malware of this type because
somebody already detected some going
back to a question most of the most of
the malware Indians are detected this
way and we kind of make a lot of
progress to to keep track of the major
of well known malicious campaigns of
Mudd war but from time to time we get
some unexpected things and we need to
start running like like wanna cry or
petea this week
these ransomware outbreaks that we need
to start thinking like okay what they
are and we need to process tons of
information in 24 hours to
get a response right and to try to think
like okay what new combination of things
can we deploy that will actually detect
this that we didn't know before some
there is information security when when
I get new people I always tell them
there are like one bad thing and one
good thing the good thing is that it
will never inherent like there is always
something new yeah and the bad thing is
that it never ends and it's always
something new is life can you justify me
and they don't and on the personal side
we studying or working in security makes
you really security aware and you try to
sometimes Infotech people are well known
for saying like oh did you tab you they
coming off your phone with the speaker
why do you you didn't do it or things
like that and yes that's also part of
what we do because we know what can
happen so we know that if you take the
precaution some you your security aware
you can avoid most of most of the common
things and another thing that we know is
that at some point someone will maybe
target you and you need to be aware of
that and for example yesterday I was
telling about a case of ahmed mansour
which is a human right activist and
blogger from image and he was targeted
with a government level spyware on his
iPhone and but he never actually got
infected because he send that
information to the citizen lab and the
researchers they'll say well yeah thank
you for not clicking on that right and
he he learned through bad experiences
that this could happen and and he
learned how to prevent it right and if
that spyware would have been on his
phone they could know every move they
could know every contact
and it was really life critical right
some it's once you get into the topic it
kind of changes you I think for good
maybe a shortcoming on it it highly
depends on which group you are working
if you're working as mala analyst or if
you are working on in computer emergency
response team or whatever um in computer
emergency response team it can get very
stressful especially if there's just a
campaign targeting you and your company
if you are working at an area for
example where you doing or the tech
sector it can be relaxed depending on
your customers yeah a lot of areas in
our t security where we are looking
people for people I know that a lot of
emergency response teams are looking for
people especially for analysts because
they just can't can't handle the data
which is coming in and so some of them
it's quite hard to identify campaign
when it's starting most of them are able
to see it when it's done yeah and
there's a lot of rotation and the field
of internal response because it he says
gets really intense and stressful and
the sub people work a couple of years
and they they move to somewhere else and
they it's always kind of refreshing and
moving even changing environments and
doing the same is good right because it
gets really intense but yeah and that
yeah this type of work is also really
challenging because they are the ones
that needs to go to the desk and say
like what is this machine infected so
what we try to do is to is to take them
machine learning to the next level which
i think is possible and say like can we
come
get better instead of saying this is
malicious car 9 that doesn't mean
anything can we say something else on
top of things like it may be a banking
Trojan infection can we can we say it is
probably adware because that even if it
seems like a small piece of information
is for the people that is responding
it's so important because it helps your
paradise and sigh like okay I'm not
going to please star running because of
oddvar I know I need to remedy a tit but
I got this other infection that maybe I
need to respond faster so I think that
with all these advances of machine
learning we we we should be able to do
more and but I think that we also have a
problem of diversity that if we want to
we are it feels from my side it always
feels like we are one step behind from
the attackers they always get in they
always find a way and we we always we
are always reactive right and if we want
to
I think machine learning is a perfect
technique because we have some
complexity that may be malicious actors
will take longer to to adopt and if we
think in 5 10 years maybe we we can do
something like it will give us the
opportunity but as I say yesterday we we
need people from other areas so to help
to look at the problem in a different
way I want to know more precisely your
take on from it important topic of woman
insecurity right like we don't have them
we need them there is no opportunity or
the problem of how to get them there and
why why we need them and which
opportunities maybe there may be in
there right I know you have like some
inciting that that it's difficult to to
get for for the rest yeah
urban insecurity thanks for a question
some
is as very complicated there is some
strong lack of woman insecurity in our
field which is in some environments like
for example in in I think in science in
general but I was so excited that in
this conference we have so good
diversity and I felt of the room where
woman I was really impressed right
insecurities is having difficult most of
the environments that are in general
that I main dominated they are harder to
get in but I think is a really good area
for for women to to actively participate
and be successful and contribute
strongly and I think that because we
have as women we have different set of
capabilities we complement each other
right with men and women and women tend
to have this ability of having a big
picture in mind all the time not go to
specialize we were talking out today
about the need of generalists the
needles people that will take different
opinions and put them together
I think that is either it's a great
thing because women have these have a
knack for these like naturally like and
I think it's a bacon break the ice and
get into a field not waiting for an
invitation just do it it's a really
exciting field and there will be
welcomed I think actually at least I
have some bad stories that I also have
like hundreds of good stories and I
think that we if you really like the
field you need just to go for it and if
there you feel there is no space for you
just make it right we are always asking
for permission we don't need to do that
nobody asks for permission before us
right so if you really like the field
and you think that you can contribute
something it just needs to do
you need to if you want to get into data
science on security issues find out of
it let your work show what you can do
and you will be embraced right because
we need that and when the only way to
get more women in securities to getting
more women in security once you have one
person you will read more but we need
more women to to their to get in without
fear of being rejected and if they are
rejected find another place right fine
find a group of people or community that
that takes you in and if you cannot find
move and find another because there is
there will be place that they will
embrace you and once you are there just
do your best and show and bring other
gears other people not only not only
women are lacking but other other people
from other countries if most mostly
there is a lot of security like our
white people InfoSec guide and it's not
that that's not right
right we need diversity not only in in
gender but in all other areas as well
because and also in disciplines right
but what I was talking in the beginning
like if you have a different background
would be amazing to have you in this
field so but I think that we should stop
asking or waiting for an invitation
because that's not going to happen we
are too worried trying to solve the
manual stuff right so I think that women
need to just go for it and and take the
chance on and do it I think I have to
take for myself at least that it really
helps to have people like you speaking
and in front of conferences and talking
about your work because then I feel like
it makes other people as I'm there
listening I can I can do this these are
problems I can work on I connect and so
I think to to encourage you know like
you're like to step up but also to thank
you for like being
a strong woman and working on this field
and these things is that it influences a
lot of people and that that means
something it makes more people get the
courage to do so too so that's also I
know there's a lot of work so I just I
want to pink and say that's that's a
very important piece of this puzzle in
my opinion yeah thank you thank you very
much
I think we can do possibly one more
question if anybody has one otherwise we
can take a break I think there will be
some outside you have you maybe one
thing at the end I think it's also
important that data scientists and
national community starts to learn a
little bit from a security expert
because I see there's how it's a very
lacks handling of data protection
security at all in this area and
[Music]
sometimes with my background I have some
bad feelings about it
honestly because it's quite too easy to
get him yeah yeah we were talking today
about these sometimes people from other
fields
that have access to information they are
not aware of the consequences or the
importance or the risk they are putting
people's lives in because they are
mishandling data right and if every
everyone I think every one of us have
the responsibility to to take a stance
on that and say like okay if you even if
you are not working on security if you
are handling people's data that is right
now really important because again it's
like the critical and the digital
colliding right and the fact that like
are we we talk many talks on that topic
that
how data data mining or I Gardens or
machine learning can influence your life
like getting a job because I don't know
your skin color is different right Susan
can we remove that feature and use
another one because that could help a
lot and is that easy but people is not
aware of the consequences that what they
are doing and it starts with I think
with everyone yeah so thank you and I
think this education is an important
thing part of why I invited Veronica
like we need to have using conversations
there sometimes these data breaches
where somebody just puts a model
somewhere and it is personally
identifiable information and the model
is serving from production and just
giving recommendations I mean it's there
for the taking
yes I think yes starting this
conversation is is really good and I
welcome more security talks at these
conferences as a commerce organizer I
would love to have more conversations
about these things and also potentially
data science folks going to security
conferences and occasionally this
actually the overlap is massive and we
have to work together yeah and some
final LaMarca there is a I think one
thing that we do bad as our security
communities that we that at least a big
portion of our community blind users
always that is a easy easy way right we
have a lot of work because you just
click on links and I work I work yeah it
looks looks legit and I was also
impacted and I didn't like it and I felt
stupid and I don't I'm not afraid of
failing and I'd say these in front of
other security professionals and they
mock me and well they are if you my my
point of view is that if you blame users
you're missing the entire point right
because when I I really reflected on why
did I click the link because I really
didn't like it and I knew it was going
to hang me forever that's why I speak of
it but I was well out under a lot of
stress I was waiting for some paper
working like information that I really
needed to be able to stay in Europe and
suddenly I got this email that I got a
package I was waiting for a package some
yeah and it was I was waiting from the
package from the company that he saved
me that I was waiting for and then I
click and it was it was bad right and I
was like well if we we try to solve
security without taking into
consideration users we will always do it
wrong we will never get it right because
like I was in a conference last year and
I asked a similar question and the
speaker said my grandmother she doesn't
need to know about security she needs
she's an end-user she needs to use the
technology so how it's possible that
after all these years we we need we
require my grandmother to actually learn
security to stay safe
well it shouldn't be that way right so
we I think we should do better and put
the users an equation and yes it brings
complexity and uncertainty and and a lot
of challenges but there is no ways to
solve it without them because I mean it
this all this cyber is a world that was
created by us and it plays I owned by
our own rules but that also means that
we can change them right we can things
build things differently but so it takes
a responsibility to say if people get
infected we cost us like security people
there is something that we are doing
wrong and probably we can do better
some yeah
thank you so much and thank you for
joining us and I would do claps but then
I'll probably just make you feel awkward